[Musique]
voici l'heure de notre rendez-vous avec
la rédaction de sciences et vie le
magazine elle a dude bonjour merci
d'être là j'ai pas de question à vous
poser
j'ai lu la une de sciences et vie les
super pouvoirs du ventre par ex il notre
vente serait capable de gérer le sommeil
le stress l'hérédité les personnalités
notre croissance entre vivacité d'esprit
notre mémoire et nos préférences
alimentaires
ça vous ressemble pas c'est sérieux
c'est très sérieux
vraiment bien sûr tout le monde en parle
du vent tu te récompense qu'il ya plein
de bouquins celui là un million
d'exemplaires
on va en profiter pour faire le point
alors d'abord c'est pas le cerveau qui
commande c'est le ventre alors plus
précisément ce pas le ventre ce sont les
bactéries qui colonisent nos intestins
le colon et l'intestin grêle il y en a
plus de dix mille milliards là dedans la
d-league milliards de bactéries à bakou
mal au coeur mais elles sont bien là il
y en a environ 500 espèces différentes
chez chaque personne ce ne sont pas les
mêmes espèces dans les mêmes quantités
en fonction de nos gènes fonction de nos
modes de vie alors il faut préciser des
bactéries on en a sur tout le corps en
réalité sauf que dans les intestins
c'est vraiment là qu'elles sont le plus
nombreuses et surtout elles sont dans un
véritable centre de commande pourquoi
parce que les intestins
c'est en fait un des tuyaux très repliée
qui sont absolument énorme et il y ait
une surface des changes avec le reste du
corps qui est énorme quand on déplie
entièrement les intestins
ça fait une surface d'environ 200 mètres
carrés ah oui de contact entre
l'intestin et l'extérieur les bactéries
exactement c'est aussi un organe qui est
très vascularisé donc ça donne plein de
réseaux de
vaisseaux sanguins qui permettent
d'échanger avec le reste du corps et
puis c'est une énorme concentration et
ça c'est moins connu de neurones
en fait c'est le deuxième organe nerveux
du corps après le cerveau les bactéries
laissent à ce que vous appelez le
microbiote microbien micro-bic revient à
teinter bon alors comment sont dans
l'ordre le moral la sociabilité le
stress en gommant l'état d'esprit c'est
là que ça se commande
oui alors pour l'instant les données
qu'on a ce sont principalement c'est
vraiment un sujet débutants donc c'est
surtout des expériences sur l'animal ces
débutants les mécanismes on ne les
connaît pas encore très bien mais il ya
quand même quelques expériences qui sont
très impressionnantes et qui montrent
des choses incroyables expériences
scientifiques
bien sûr très sérieuse on a par exemple
des chercheurs qui récemment ont
interverti les microbes intestinaux de
deux souches de souris différentes une
souche était naturellement plutôt
stressé l'autre beaucoup moins et en
intervertissant leur microbiote la
souche stressé est devenu beaucoup moins
et la souche paisible est devenu
beaucoup plus stressés pourrait être la
même chose chez nous les humains oui en
fait c'est quelque chose qu'on observe
même si on n'a pas des preuves aussi
forte
on sait que les personnes qui sont
touchées par des troubles anxieux ont
des troubles aussi souvent intestinaux
des troubles du microbiote ça pourrait
s'expliquer par une influence du
microbiote sur le stress bon deuxième
expérience scientifique vous dites la
mémoire il ya des le rhône et la mémoire
c'est aussi la wii des chercheurs
l'année dernière ont perturbé le
microbiote de souris en leur donnant un
régime alimentaire volontairement
déséquilibré et les souris au microbiote
déséquilibré notamment ils ont noté une
augmentation du nombre de bactéries
qu'on appelle clostridium s qui
visiblement ne sont pas très bonnes pour
nous et pour les souris ces souris ont
été moins bonnes aux tests de mémoire et
août est de capacités cognitives plus
généralement qui leur ont été données
quand elles avaient leur microbiote qui
était altéré le métabolisme les
l'obésité oui oui oui oui effectivement
l'obésité c'est aussi on sait que les
personnes obèses ont un microbiote
altérée par rapport aux personnes
ans en moyenne ce micro bien des
différents et une hypothèse est que le
microbiote seraient responsables de nos
variations de susceptibilité à la prise
de poids entre individus on sait assez
logique finalement puisque le microbiote
il est clairement impliqué dans la
digestion ça c'est quelque chose qu'on
sait depuis longtemps
évidemment mais des études suggèrent
qu'il serait aussi impliqué dans la
régulation de notre appétit voir de nos
préférences alimentaires
c'est là que ça se passe et palau
attendait elsa dans votre article de
science et vie vous dites que le ventre
les super pouvoirs dû vendre sa règle
aussi le sommeil la croissance
l'hérédité les défenses la vieillesse
pour les résister par exemple oui
l'hérédité c'est lié au fait que puisque
nos bactéries influencent nos caractères
et on sait que la mère transmet ces
bactéries à son enfant lors de
l'accouchement et peut-être même lors de
la grossesse alors ces bactéries
pourraient être responsables de la
transmission des caractères de la mère à
ses enfants un peu comme les gènes
finalement le pouvoir des bactéries
voilà et du coup les enfants nés par
césarienne qui ne bénéficient pas des
bactéries vaginale de la mer lors d'un
accouchement par les voies naturelles
ces bactéries colonisant normalement
leurs intestins et dans à leur
développement
ces enfants nés par césarienne ont plus
de maladies résultat les médecins sont
en train d'envisager de donner ces
bactéries aux enfants nés par césarienne
en vraiment en récupérant un an chez un
échantillon chez la mère et en le
déposant sur la peau de l'enfant pour
qu'il cède
martin l'enfant et pour qu'ils puissent
être colonisé juste après la naissance
on avait parlé un de ces bactéries dans
une précédente émission rappel vous
pouvez le revoir ou le revoir sur le
site internet de sciences et vie ou de
sciences et vie télé pour les images
merci merci est la bonne que vous disent
vos bactéries vous avez en feu s'abat
n'est pas dedans vie particulière j'ai
l'impression qu'elle s'opposait de ma
part merci à très bientôt pour une
nouvelle chronique voilà c'est déjà la
fin de cette émission mais comme il
reste encore plein de choses à découvrir
à la télé ou dans le magazine on va se
retrouver très bientôt pour un nouvel
épisode du mac de la science et en
attendant n'oubliez jamais jamais que la
curiosité mais surtout pas un vilain
défaut
à bientôt
[Musique]